22 million people are now living under
some form of tighter covered
restrictions
and once you're in a local lockdown it's
pretty hard to escape
just ask the people of greater
manchester who've endured nine weeks of
tougher rules on who they can meet
and where
and in that time the number of daily
cases has gone up
fourfold in bolton people have been
making big sacrifices
at least most people has been the
biggest thing is the isolation and
people
not being connected with so as being
part of a church we've made a decision
that with the correct guidelines and
social distances that we're going to
connect with people again and do what we
can
that regardless of a lockdown through
social media through online presence
we're going to connect with people
because
being isolated is really tough it's
really tough i've barely seen any
difference to be honest
all my mates are still going out and
stuff so i
yeah i don't think it i don't think it's
worked life is very difficult it's very
hard especially for businesses
very very quiet seriously it's very bad
local lockdowns have been key to the
government's strategy in the words of
the prime minister the whack-a-mole
approach to keeping coveyed infections
down
but are they working and if they're not
does the government need to change its
approach
when restrictions were brought in
greater manchester was seeing between
100
and 150 new cases of covert 19 each day
but in recent weeks that number has
risen sharply
reaching 826 just 10 days ago
and that trend can also be seen at a
more local level these are just four of
the areas in greater manchester under
local restrictions
in all of them the number of infections
per 100 000 people has increased since
the tita rules were imposed
now some of this rise is down to
increase testing of the local population
but not all across those same four areas
the proportion of coronavirus tests
returning a positive result
has also gone up suggesting that the
increased spread of coping 19
is genuine it's been a really tough time
to be honest and
i think people are from being frank
fed up uh with the situation it's
because they're so complex
um hard to understand and sometimes
there's a conflict with national rules
so for instance the rule of six
uh doesn't apply in the same way to
areas with
local restrictions on gathering in the
homes in homes or in public venues so
it's the confusion that they create and
kind of the the ongoing nature of them
once you're in you never seem to be able
to escape
from them it's like the hotel california
syndrome you know you check in and you
can never leave and i think people are
you know become become quite fed up and
are asking
what difference are they actually making
that's a key question isn't it does feel
as if
what's the exit strategy is there any
way of getting out of these lockdowns
and if you look at the infection rates
in greater manchester
it's pretty depressing they're still
going up why do you think that is
well i go back to when national lockdown
was lifted
i said it then and i say it now it was
lifted too early for the north of
england
the cases were much higher here than
they were in london at the time
and i think it was a decision to lift
lockdown which was mainly made with
london
in mind and we've struggled uh ever
since ever since then
and in terms of what we do from here
i think if we're being fair the
restrictions had an impact initially
in that they dampened the increasing
cases and helped us begin to
bring them back down but i would say
their effectiveness
uh has been limited and diminishes the
longer
that they are in in terms of the exit
strategy well i've got a simple one for
the government
local restrictions should come with
local control
of the test and trace system because
that still
isn't working for greater manchester if
you put that under local control at
least our own destiny would be in our
hands
and we then could work to bring the
levels of
the spread of the virus down in our
boroughs and we'd have an incentive to
be able to get ourselves out of these
restrictions at the moment it feels
that we're a little powerless sophie
we're under these restrictions and we
don't have as much
agencies we need to try and lift them
you were talking about how you think the
restrictions did have a
positive impact driving down case
numbers at the beginning but that's
faded off is that because people are
simply
no longer sticking to the rules what's
your data
on compliance no it's pretty
high i mean they're always going to be
some people who who don't
comply but it it was clearly
the case in the early days that people
did follow the restrictions and as i say
the case numbers came down
what then happened though was a move by
the government working with some of its
mps to
start to create a patchwork of
restrictions so it started to
uh ask where the boroughs should be
withdrawn and then it became very
complicated
uh sophie and then we had uh national
messages which
conflicted with the local restrictions
the rule of six being an example
and more recently the 10 pm curfew that
i've mentioned
so you know all of this becomes really
complicated
so frankly people haven't been
necessarily following the rules
in the way that the government intended
more recently whether or not you blame
the complexity of the rules or the fact
that they didn't get the buy-in or the
government's messaging was wrong
is that the real reason why some of
these local lockdowns have been less
effective
more recently we need a bit of a reset
here
so that people can clearly understand
what's being asked and the government
are talking about tears now aren't they
you know tier one which will be national
restrictions and then a second tier that
would be the additional restrictions on
top of that
that probably would help clarify uh
things
for people but i've certainly felt this
week that we've reached a bit of a
tipping point with all of this
the government are really in danger of
losing the public in the north of
england
and actually if they carry on imposing
restrictions on the north
without proper support for the
businesses and the employees affected in
the north
we will see a winter of leveling down
and the north-south divide getting
bigger
and a government that says it's
committed to the opposite shouldn't even
be thinking about that
and many in the area say they found it
hard to keep track of the ever-changing
restrictions
there were some people who just didn't
follow it
but i think there's also a large section
of people who
were just confused by it and haven't
been very sure
what exactly it is they're supposed to
be doing so for example
i live in manchester a lot of my friends
live in stockport
um not necessarily that far away um but
we're continually having to try and work
out what it is that they can do and what
it is
that i can do and they keep asking me
because i'm covering it on a daily basis
and very often i can't remember i can't
work out and i have to go back and check
now if that's the case for me that gives
you some
sense of what it's like for the general
public
whether it's because of the messaging
genuine confusion or people
frankly just not following the rules the
figures tell a pretty clear story that
postcode lockdowns aren't working in the
way the government hoped
the question now is what do they do
about it